thank you yasser yes we are indeed with
another victory of today's round that is
begging tokyo nova after her victory
against nemtsova begging welcome back to
the studio welcome back to st louis this
is the first time after the us chess
championships back in st louis how does
that feel thank you very much it feels
great now we are playing without the
mask and the time control is different i
i'm happy to be here
talk to us a little bit about that time
control and the format of this event
it's a double elimination round robin
how does that feel and also the time
control because you don't get the second
time control
yeah i have never played double nation
so it's going to be my first
experience and i'm kind of very excited
about that and
when it comes to time control i like it
more than like having more time
sometimes like
people spend half an hour when they have
already like losing position after move
40 which is kind of unpleasant so here
it's faster and i like faster games more
let's go uh through today's game take us
uh through the opening phase and then
the middle game and when you feel like
you're taking over
to be honest uh
i thought c4 was a wrong move i thought
after knight d2 uh i'm better and
whatever she did in the opening felt a
little bit
slow for me and then here i thought i'm
better but
then i start to realize i really don't
have anything she played knight d2
and i took on c4
b4
and here i thought she could play rook
d1 instead of rook a2
maybe fd1 or rook 81 rook 81 maybe
and then she wants to play bishop c3 and
slowly getting back to pawn
i thought i was much better than i
started to realize i'm not that
like
she's probably going to regain her pawn
yeah slowly she can like develop ruketo
was very strange move after that
it's just
still she has some chances of course
here because because she has two bishops
but unfortunately she didn't have any
time
so
she wasn't very precise
and what was the final moment in this
end game or uh
okay here i knew i should uh like
i should be winning slowly even though
we have like different
opposition
bishops yeah here i thought maybe f6
instead of f5
uh and slowly i have maybe slowly
developed the pieces then i wasn't sure
after rook d2 rook d8 is coming so i
thought f5 and rook d6
is better for me
and at some point i thought maybe it's
it's draw and i cannot win the position
like win the game
at what moment did you feel like you
have lost like around here i i felt like
i i lost con i lost control over the
position it's just like
it felt uh
very
good to have the position but then i
realized that it's so hard to play
so somewhere around here you would kind
of reconcile that the game is probably
going to peter out into it yeah i was
hoping that she
she will
make a mistake because otherwise it
feels like if she puts bishop isabel or
something like bishop g5 it's
immediately draw so i started to
like
realize that and try to escape that
positions and luckily she made some
mistakes
so about where did it really really go
wrong now at this point you've got two
connected past pawns yeah and probably
it's already gone here i was confident
that i'm going to be in the position
unfortunately if you don't have you you
don't have enough time you it's very
hard to protect these positions right
you should be very very precise
everywhere so i was kind of like
i was sure that i'm going to be in the
game but before after i played f4 i
thought probably she's going to hold the
position i got you and it was a very
strange game because i felt like i was
doing okay and at some point everything
just disappeared
wonderful thank you for sharing thank
you very much becky man we'll see you
tomorrow thank you very much well done